conservez enrichir accumulé sauver
multiplier inventé autant de verbes pour
qualifier ceux qui président à la
création du festival cette année
la trentaine de jardins sélectionné
oscille entre collections botaniques et
esprit du collectionneur la mise en
scène va du cabinet de curiosités à la
galerie d'art
l'idée c'était mettre en évidence des
métiers parfois oubliés des savoirs au
fond d'un jardin au fond d'une serre de
pépiniéristes remarquable qui
collectionne qui obtiennent qui
multiplie des espèces végétales des
raretés botanique eux dont on n'a pas
souvent conscience d'autres paysagistes
ont travaillé sur une interprétation
différente de ce thème et nous ont
emmenés au musée comme un écho aux
préoccupations actuelles sur la perte de
la biodiversité
le festival offre une richesse de
végétaux rares singulier introuvables ou
étonnants des diversités
cette bio diversité et cette rareté
végétal c'était pour nous important
parce que nous sommes dans un festival
de jardin le visiteur s'attend à trouver
des légers tôt qu'il ne connaît pas un
peu inattendu et c'est une manière de
sensibiliser aussi notre public à
l'importance de cette biodiversité qui
on le sait se réduit d'année en année à
cause de la standardisation à cause de
la simplification qui intervient dans
notre univers
de boer
les équipes qui réussissent le concours
sont souvent en effet des équipes qui
ont entre 25 et 35 ans on peut expliquer
sa part le fait que chaumont est un
tremplin pour le jeune paysagiste et l'
avantage pour chaumont sur loire c'est
que ce sont des équipes très attentive
par ce canton
on n'a pas trop avancer dans la vie
professionnelle
on utilise les végétaux on utilise les
matériaux on les associe de manière
originale proposée par des équipes
pluridisciplinaires paysagistes
jardiniers artistes architectes ces
jardins ont tous un intérêt botanique et
scénographique
il y est question de fleurs fantôme
d'archers de déluge de jardins de
babylone et même une cargaison abandonné
lice en fait c'est qu'on a imaginé que
notre notre jardin prenait forme sur le
tarmac d'un aéroport et que du coup les
caisses les caisses en bois sont empilés
stockées sur ces grandes étagères en
métal et elles sont en fait comme des
bagages oublié ou non réclamés par leurs
propriétaires qui existe treize mille
fougères dans le monde
là on a un échantillon de 250 taxant à
peu près sur le total c'est une petite
une petite représentation mais on
voulait montrer aux visiteurs une
vraiment vraiment la richesse en fait et
la diversité
ça se rapproche un peu des murs végétaux
de patrick blanc là on pourrait appeler
ça plus un jardin superposés ou qu'on
peut très bien imaginer dans une cour
intérieure en milieu urbain avec
d'autres plantes éventuellement on peut
soi-même créer des jardins créer des
oeuvres collectionner il faut que nous
nous rapprochions de nos publics on a
tous les publics on a les experts mais
tout le monde n'est pas un expert mais
chacun peut le devenir
il faut donner le goût le goût du beau
le goût du rare le goût de la diversité
des objets et du végétal une fois encore
le festival international des jardins
scène cette année des graines
d'inventivité et de connaissance du
vivant
une façon singulière de proposer à
chacun de s'interroger sur la richesse
et l'utilité du patrimoine végétal dans
nos paysages